everyone's asking what is metamask how
do you use it what are the mistakes that
i need to avoid when using the metamask
wall well in this video i'm going to
tell you exactly what is metamask how to
use it and watch the end to see what
mistakes to avoid when using the
metamask wallet metamask is a crypto
wall and also a gateway to other
blockchain applications you can use
metamask on your mobile device on ios or
android or you can also use it on your
internet browser both firefox brave
chrome pretty much any browser that
supports the internet people use
metamask for a variety of things most
people use it to either store their nfts
ethereum or other ethereum related
tokens metamask has integrated with a
bunch of key blockchain and
cryptocurrency applications one of the
main ones is openc openc currently is
the number one place to go buy and sell
nfts so this makes perfect sense why
metamask will be integrating with openc
metamask has over 30 million users while
openc only has around just over a
million users a quote from crypto
software giant consensus reads a global
user base relies on metamasks to mint
and collect nfts join dows and
participate in d5 protocols the united
states the philippines brazil germany
and nigeria represent some of metamasks
most active markets this makes a lot of
sense because this is where
cryptocurrency is being adopted the most
and this is where metamask is
penetrating in those markets so if we
think about metamask as the door into
your house into crypto then you want to
protect that house with everything you
can metamask there are a lot of mistakes
you need to avoid when using metamask
one of the mistakes is forgetting or
losing your seed phrase it is a 12 word
phrase given to you and automatically
generated by metamask that can help you
access your account and your funds in
case you forget or misplace your
password so more mistakes to avoid are
not letting your computer get hacked and
letting people access your metamask wall
through your own hardware device another
common mistake to avoid is don't connect
your metamask wallet to unknown services
servers or groups so you don't want to
go ahead and give someone your wallet id
and your seed phrase and give them
everything and all your access to your
metamask wall you want to keep this as
tight and as closely and privately as
possible do your own research and follow
this advice and in the end we're all
gonna make it hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time